All right.
Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Birr and it's time for a special episode of the Monday
morning podcast.
It's not on Monday.
It's not on Thursday.
It's coming out,
I guess what?
Tuesday,
Wednesday.
We're going to put this out as soon as we can.
I have a special guest here.
You know I don't do a lot of guests,
so if I bring somebody in,
they gotta be a heavy hitter.
They got to be a mover,
a shaker,
a shot caller.
We have the one and only Judd Apatow here.
Pleasure to be here.
John,
how are you buddy?
I liked the beer.
Usually.
You're all by yourself just talking to the wall.
Yes I am.
And usually you're in the midst of producing,
which fascinates me.
I tried to,
uh,
talk to you about this because a,
I like to think I'm kind of a busy man too.
How you manage to have movies,
TV shows,
stand up,
special masterclass,
a documentary on Garry Shandling.
How they'll fuck manager.
Keep all like how big is the bolt and the war room?
It's all management technique.
That's what you want to know.
I'll tell you a good management technique.
The staff of crashing the room right now,
writing the fourth season,
third season comes on in January,
but they writing the fourth season and I'm here with you.
Yes,
that's managed.
So,
so how do you check in with that?
How do I check that every day?
Do they send you a draft and you just kind of keep it in bounds of where it
needs to be or at season four?
Is it sort of up and running?
Well,
usually what it is is Pete and I,
uh,
and also the Judith Miller and Oren who work on the show.
We'll kick around a little bit what we think the season might be.
We bring in writers for a month and we just kick it around very openly,
like anything is on the table.
And I'll pop in and out of those meetings and,
and then there's notes and I'll read the notes and then sit in for half a day
and then take a day off and then pop back in.
And usually that gives me some perspective.
Because you've been in those rooms.
There's a lot of Chinese food,
there's a lot of danishes he get tired.
Launch is huge.
There's a lot of people talking about things that have nothing to do with the
show for very long periods of time.
Uh,
and then at some point I'll sit with Pete and we'll go through everything and
go,
okay,
which ideas do we like?
You know,
my favorite thing is,
is the mental break you take in the writer's room,
it's like you're pitching,
you're pitching,
then you're fried.
And like I always look around the room and I'll just see someone hasn't pitched
him in it and then just sort of staring down at the ground for about 15,
20 minutes and then they just come back up the light.
Yeah.
All right.
What if frank did deaf?
If I can,
but you literally you have to do it.
And um,
what I learned on f is for family though,
is I didn't realize how fried you get yes.
In the writer's room.
And like my drinking went off the rails a little bit.
It was one little scotch.
And then it just became like three.
So last season.
And what time of day though?
Are you having your Scotch in the room?
Oh,
not in the room now.
It was when I got home.
When I got home,
I would literally just,
you know,
put on the fireplace,
turn it on now cause you don't light a fire anymore.
You just turn it on and then I would just sit there like uh,
yeah.
And it was getting to that shit.
It was just like I need this at the end of the day.
So in season three,
like I did this thing,
I go not only may not drink and this season I'm actually gonna try to do the
impossible,
which is drop weight.
And I was from,
which I did,
oh hi.
I packed a lunch.
Like I was a second grader.
So every day that they would be going out now I had like this keen what being
thing that I would always have.
And then yeah,
just fruit,
nuts,
you know,
it would be my,
my snacks or whatever.
Cause it's all reward.
You want to reward yourself,
you need to get to work,
whatever,
nine,
10 o'clock and all you think all morning is that they get 1230,
the food's going to lay a hand.
Oh yeah,
the food's going to land.
Then we can stop talking about this show and eat this food.
And if everybody voted a place that you fucking hate.
Yeah,
it's just like,
that is the longest day ever.
But if you're going into like,
you know,
it's like a Friday and they picked an awesome like lunch place like that can
literally,
you pitched better.
But I like that you are not in charge of that because the only area I will throw
my weight around is if they say,
hey,
we're going to eat here today.
I'm very comfortable going,
we are not going there today.
Daddy needs this.
No,
there's definitely a,
there's a,
uh,
there's also,
there's a generation gap and that also goes with nutrition,
you know,
so there's people like,
my show takes place in the 70s,
so that's,
there's people that grew up in the seventh and the other people who were born in
the 80s.
So there they're more likely to go to something a little more healthy than the
old sort of John Wayne people in the room.
I'm like,
I'm not eating that shit.
And some days there's a little bit of a mutiny,
but it's not about the writers from here.
I actually,
they sent me,
which was really cool.
Thank you.
You guys send me a link to the first episode of season three of crashing with
the Great Pete Holmes.
And,
uh,
just once again,
it's like,
like watching that show,
I've,
I've lived this,
I don't want to give away a what the episode is about,
but I mean,
in generally speaking,
it's like Pete has now gotten to the point where he actually has his own place,
which is awesome.
And he's mentoring a young man.
Yes.
Yabuki from,
uh,
the daily show was on the daily show.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Who's great at it.
So he finally feels cocky enough to give someone else advice.
Yeah.
I have to sit and talk to my keys in the mix.
He's kind of feeling himself a little bit and as always,
this business will humble you.
So he ends up getting humbled in.
It's like,
uh,
just the way the,
the,
uh,
how you,
when he gets humbled,
I don't want to say it is the way it's written that uh,
he then lashes out at this person that he kind of smoothed stuff over with.
And that's just like the worst,
especially with a woman.
Then you get that whole,
you're enjoying this,
aren't you?
You're enjoying that.
I mean,
I literally had that fight with my wife like two days ago.
Um,
what does she enjoy then?
I lost my temper.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
and then she gets,
like,
you know how the deal is,
you know,
with women,
nothing is off bounds.
But like with you,
you have to stay within the lines are all,
she'll never hear the end of it.
So,
you know,
she,
she was driving the car all over the place,
all over my life.
Let
me know who I was.
But you know,
she was right about a lot of it.
And uh,
that's the worst part is that they are right about a lot of it.
No,
but they're all so wrong.
So I did this,
this whole period now where women,
like,
they went from nobody listening to them to now everything that they say is spun
with gold is just,
it's,
it's getting ridiculous.
I was like,
we have to be okay,
let's,
you know,
women are like,
guys,
a lot of them are just full of Shit,
you know,
as our men.
So,
I mean that's the art of life is trying to figure out who actually has the
information that you need,
which is why when I talked to you how to,
you know,
manage a shell,
you have the goods with everything you've got going on here.
Um,
well sometimes you know,
the thing about it is that you do need someone who has the perspective to judge
ideas and how things are going.
So there's a process of generating maybe a thousand ideas for a show,
but if you're burnt out from being part of that generation,
it's hard for you to pick what works.
And so like at girls I was very involved in the writing,
but I wouldn't go to the set because it was so well directed.
There was no reason for me to be there.
The footage always was great.
And Lena and January graded monitoring the directors and directing themselves.
At what point did you have confidence to be like,
all right,
this thing is cruising?
Well,
I don't think I ever felt like it was,
it was,
it was cruising,
but I had confidence in if the script was good,
they would shoot it great.
And then I could put all my energy into just reading the scripts to give them a,
a person who could tell them if the script's worked,
you know,
so they were tired from shooting and writing and they're exhausted and I,
I'm able to have a little more energy to just read and go on page four.
It's weird.
Why did they say that?
It's not tracking and it's,
that's hard to do when you're in the thick of it and you're exhausted and so
there is a value to,
you know,
picking where you're helpful and where you're like,
you don't need me here.
I don't have to sit and look at over the director's shoulder.
You're nailing it.
Let me save that energy for the writing part.
I hate to admit this,
but actually enjoy being in the writer's room.
Oh yeah.
I was like kicking and screaming,
thinking about,
God,
I'm a comedian.
I'm free.
Why the fuck am I going to go back and into some math class or whatever and I
should say this on days where it's working.
Yes,
it's working and it's cruising and we're getting good notes,
you know?
Um,
we always get good notes by me,
positive notes from Netflix,
like we enjoy this,
but then on the days where like this doesn't really,
there's too much of that.
And then we go,
all right and then we try to fix it and then it's just not working.
Those are the days where I feel like I'm back in high school and I'm just,
it's like,
it's the clock broken.
Like what,
what are we doing here?
So you're the teacher.
That's the thing,
you know,
when you work on the show and you're not the teacher,
like at the Larry Sanders show,
if we did a table read and what's working,
then suddenly there is someone upset with you,
right?
And you are ashamed child that at the script and work up and you're,
then you're like,
how can I fix it?
And,
and,
and there's almost a daddy or mommy character that you're disappointing if the
show isn't working or if the script isn't working.
There's a lot,
a lot of ways for it to be super unhealthy,
but it is more fun.
You're right when you're that person and you can treat people well and you have
your own strong point of view,
it's not as painful.
Yeah.
I would say in my room at Mike prices,
he's the captain of the ship.
So I'm the guy that's sorta chimes in and tries to like,
I dunno,
uh,
keep it like certain things tethered to reality if it,
if it starts getting a little too like absurd.
But you know,
you brought up Gary Shandling who like,
you know,
anybody who is even remotely in the comedy just,
I mean like guys like on the Mount Rushmore there.
And uh,
I just remember,
you know,
I watched,
this is the theme,
the gallery show.
I watched this first one.
I watched everything.
I used to watch this tonight show sets.
I just always just thought the guy,
he just always,
it was funny when even like when I was in junior junior highs,
like in seventh grade,
I knew that his stuff was just funnier.
That it was like,
this is like a different level.
Like this guy is better than all of these other guys.
And I was wondering what,
like what was that like,
you know,
cause I,
I really,
I sent an email about that.
Like I thought the Garry Shandling documentary that you did was that,
that's my favorite thing you've done.
And I think 40 year old virgin and all this stuff.
But um,
what was that like because you were friends with somebody?
Sure.
Like that.
Um,
you know,
myself,
I've lost a couple of friends and I know that certain things,
it just gets like really emotional what was,
but I never delved into their life.
To the level that you did with,
with Gary,
who was like a friend and a mentor to you.
Like what was that process like?
Like,
how long did it take you to,
to,
you know,
cause that was on par with like,
did you see that eagles documentary?
I love that.
It was like three hours long and a fellow,
he was 20 minutes.
Yeah.
And it's just like I got through like a cross country flight watching that.
I felt like that Gary Shandling duck was like that.
What was that like?
It was like the Eagles Doc.
If,
if Gary,
uh,
wasn't on coke.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's funny cause now that it's over and I've been,
I finished at six or eight months ago,
something like that.
Looking back,
it's almost like a fever dream that I even did it right.
Because he died.
I was really depressed.
It through me more than I thought because he was a constant presence of support
and I didn't realize what an important beam he was in everything.
And,
and uh,
and I thought,
I think there's just a lesson that he wants to teach everybody.
And I'll tell you a story that it kind of launched the documentary is that I
went to Gary's cremation.
And so Gary's cremation was very,
I mean,
people don't go to cremations.
You're not supposed to go to cremation.
What you sound like sliding the body in.
Well kind of it's Jesus judge basically,
you know,
basically.
Uh,
how did you get the tickets to that?
And I only saw,
I only tell this story because I think it's,
it,
it's is helpful to people in their own lives is that a,
you know,
a friend put together a very small service.
So if you can imagine there's only like eight people there and you know,
oven basically.
And,
and like for a Buddhist monks,
right?
So he takes the edge off a little bit like that here.
They're not freaking out.
Yeah,
they were fine with it.
That's their whole religion.
Okay.
So we go to this place and it's in the valley and it's not that far from these
offices and it's,
you know,
a crematorium.
Is it part of a strip mall is like ramen noodles.
Get your tax done,
watching your friend get burned.
Even worse.
It's deeper in the valley where it's just next to a place that like,
you know,
makes glass bowls or something send in an industrial area.
So we go there,
it's clear no one's ever had a service in this space.
This isn't what people do,
right?
So there's no like room to do it.
We're literally in like the lobby of a place that looks like a sham business of
some someplace,
right?
And like what they're selling in the lobby,
there's literally just like one desk and empty space.
And did you make sure it was Gary underneath [inaudible] fucking,
he should have crash test dummy.
Like that'll be 50 grand.
Like what they were selling there.
They had these little,
these little pamphlets where you could take some of the ashes of your beloved
and have them put into like a little glass figurine you could put on your table
or like something you would wear.
Medical itself gone,
gone.
So we go,
we go to this,
this place.
And,
uh,
we go into this little room and again,
it's like it couldn't be ratty or really,
and the,
they have,
uh,
a service,
which is very sweet and it's beautiful and,
and,
and moving and all of the ideas of,
of Buddhism and the,
and,
uh,
and then they take us in this room.
Now the room with the crematorium,
it's like the kitchen to a restaurant.
It's just like a big room with a cement floor and like four or five oven,
they did a little service.
They hit some little fucking gongs or something.
Like what happened.
Yeah,
they're just,
they did Buddhist prayers and they talked about Carrie's life and,
uh,
and,
and what life is about,
you know,
you,
you live,
you die,
you,
you learn the lessons that you can,
you try to be as loving and kindness.
You can hopefully you,
uh,
you know,
you grew and it was very sweet.
That actually sounds cool.
Now,
did they believe in a heaven and Hell Buddhist people?
Here's my issue.
Buddhism is as you get deeper and deeper into it,
it had to reincarnation.
I,
I believe,
and I always get lost when things get too magical.
I like something that's clear,
like life is about being kind and that's it.
Like that's,
that's as far as I usually can get.
I can see this script writer in you,
things,
you know,
you need it to land
is
magical in any way.
As soon as someone's reborn and it goes to heaven or hell,
I'm,
I've lost,
I have trouble now.
I'm not 100% closed,
but I'm pretty close.
Uh,
but I do,
I can get interested in ideas that are about how can we let go of our egos and
be kind.
That's all I need.
Okay.
So we have the service and it's,
and it's bringing into the other moving and then we go in the other room
and it's literally a table with a cardboard coffin.
And then they say some more prayers.
And then at some point they open up an oven,
which looks like almost like a dishwasher in a restaurant.
And they roll it into flames already going or do they turn it on after they
closed the door?
There's a pilot light and uh,
and then they stick it to,
it's literally not that far from a pizza oven.
Okay.
And you know,
they put,
uh,
the cardboard coffin,
then they close,
close it illness.
Like if a dishwasher in a restaurant and then they ask who wants to push the
button?
Oh Jesus.
And you know,
they're saying they have a bunch of fake buttons,
like a firing squad.
Like somebody gets flanks and one guy really blows his brains out.
He had no one wants to know who,
who pushed,
you don't want to carry that.
And then a friend of Gary's,
you know,
push the button and then suddenly you hear it fire up,
it's getting hotter than your normal pizza oven and the room gets hot.
And then it's like you smell something burning.
Like it's like,
you know,
if it was like a fire at your neighbor's house and suddenly like your chest
hurts a little bit,
then you realize it's Gary,
isn't it?
There's no vent I guess.
I guess I it maybe it was a place that needed more ventilation.
No,
I mean there is a vent.
It's not like overpowering,
like the room is all filled with smoke,
but you do realize like someday if you go on a fast to get rid of toxins in your
body,
part of that is Garry Shandling.
Exactly.
And that would sadden me.
But,
but that's what was crazy about it.
So now I love Gary so much.
I will never go on a fast after I breathe.
Wow.
So,
so I'm,
you know,
watching this,
crying my eyes out,
just balling.
It's as intense as anything I've ever experienced.
This,
it's pretty heavy and I'm feeling it in my chest and I'm aware like that's scary
.
We're breathing in Gary.
And at first,
you know,
part of me,
it made me laugh like,
yeah cause this is super creepy dude.
It's creepy.
It's kind of weirdly like the Gary always would make the joke like I'm inside
you.
You know,
like there's like a sexual joke to be made there.
And then I just thought,
God,
Gary would find this so funny.
All of us sitting here crying,
watching them cremate his body,
he would think that this was fantastic like me here bawling my eyes out.
Gary would look and just go like,
that's right.
That's what it is.
And,
and I thought in that moment,
this is a lesson like having to look at that will change your life.
Having to be at the crematorium about,
you know,
what's important?
What do we care about?
How do we treat people?
What do you want to do with your life?
And I thought,
Gary wanted me here.
He wanted me to go through this hell in this freaking,
you know,
oh,
is this part of his like,
no,
he didn't ask for it,
but I decided in like a spiritual level.
I thought,
this is it.
Gary wants me to learn every freaking lesson to the point of his incineration.
He wants me to look at in the eye and take from it whatever I can take to be a
better person.
And I think in that moment was,
you know,
the seed of how do I tell other people this lesson?
Because I think in Gary's life he was trying to figure out how to talk about
this stuff.
And you know,
it's very hard in comedy to do it without seeming really corny or weird.
You know,
as soon as people start talking about their spirituality in a sincere way,
we're all like,
shut the fuck up.
And it feels,
you gotta be interviewed by Oprah and she has to bring it out of you and act
like,
well,
she asked me exactly,
only waited.
That's the only cool way to do it.
I mean,
I had so many friends that tried to,
and they always seemed odd.
And I think Gary,
when he did comedians in cars getting coffee was the first time he found a way
to be really funny,
but talk about some things that he believed in.
And I think that was his goal near the end of his life.
He's trying to figure out how to reinvent how he did stand up and get some of
these ideas in and he hadn't quite cracked it.
He was really into silence.
He loved not getting a laugh.
He loved putting people through weird silences and he would say to the crowd
that that's where it all is.
It's all in that silence.
Right?
And he didn't have a joke.
He didn't even know what to do with it.
He just knew when the room went dead contemplating is what they're doing.
They're contemplating what was just said.
And so what I was working at his memorial service,
I cut together four or five little mini docs about Gary and when I was making
them I thought,
oh yeah,
there's a whole movie about Carrie about what he believed in and,
and that's how it started.
It's incredible.
And it just came out on Blu Ray.
There was still have the blue ray players,
you know,
I still have,
I have a DVD VCR player but my TV's too advanced and I can hook it up to that
cell if anybody knows that there's some sort of adapter or some other thing I
can do to try to make that work,
I would appreciate it.
But,
uh,
there's a lot of shit cause you know,
I,
you know,
finally became a parent so I had to get my affairs in order.
Yeah.
You know,
you know,
it's a guy,
you've got to make sure everybody's going to be okay.
You got the will you and I get like to the point like I gave,
I hooked my wife up so much like she has motive.
Like if I die suddenly,
um,
I've had the conversation with my wife and the insurance agent,
have you done this conversation yet where you sit with an insurance agent about
life insurance?
And he's like,
well,
Judd lifted this age,
you get this.
If he,
if he lives at this age,
you get that and,
and it's gambling or gambling on me dying and betting against yourself,
like
died before you thought I was going to.
Now you've got to give them all this money and my wife wouldn't
by the extra insurance cause she said,
I feel really weird,
uh,
you know,
having any,
handicapping your death.
And she was deeply upset at the conversation.
That was like six or seven years ago.
And just the other day she's like,
maybe we should get that insurance.
Yeah,
that sort of happens after a,
I,
you know,
I want you to have kids and stuff,
but like,
I,
uh,
you know,
I went with the cremation thing.
I think it's so stupid to stick yourself in the box.
And then the Nike like you that important that there's gotta be like a headset,
I guess is for the living people to have someplace to go.
But,
uh,
I think now just with the world population,
I mean the graveyards at some point,
I mean they,
I don't know if they going to dig deeper.
If you're going to be underneath somebody else.
But,
uh,
I've had a lot of people go,
well,
what if you still feel stuff?
And it's just like,
well then let's get it over with.
Which friend of yours thinks you still feel stuff?
A lot of people are afraid of,
uh,
of death.
It's just the stuff that,
you know,
something I don't even know.
Cause I,
I,
my short term memory is bad,
but a lot of people say that about like,
you know,
if you get cremated,
what if you still feel stuff?
It's like,
well,
I'd rather just get it over with in a minute.
I guess I die again somehow in that minute.
But,
uh,
rather than laying there waiting for the worms to slowly work their fucking way
in,
burn it and toss it out of an airplane,
I want to go,
I want to,
I wish I don't just probably isn't legal in this country,
but I want to do it like the Viking way.
Like,
make a little ship.
Sure.
Send me out there.
It gives people,
shoots some flaming arrows,
you know,
giving them a little contest.
It's like a burn it on the Ganges.
Yeah.
It's like a clay pigeon type of thing.
But um,
anyways,
uh,
what else we got?
We got a benefit coming up too that you're doing a,
at the Gramercy for the Ronald McDonald House is one of the great,
um,
uh,
charities out there.
You can go to John [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
That's January 15th.
Uh,
Graham is the Gramercy theater.
Yeah.
In the,
in New York.
And it's a Pete and John Malaney.
Pete Holmes.
Normally Regina Spektor and some cast members from,
uh,
from crashing like gooky and Jamie Lee and me.
And uh,
yeah,
that's where the Ronald Mcdonald's house,
which is
monster lineup.
John Malaney,
man,
that guy's just,
he's just a in New York,
England and New York Genius Guy.
Um,
so,
uh,
all right.
What else?
What else we can,
we,
uh,
can we discuss here?
We've,
we've,
we've promoted,
we've promoted whose law away your master class?
I have a masters in the presence of them.
How do you get,
how do you like get the,
somebody approach you with like,
uh,
with something like that?
Like you want to,
just like I could teach a master class on how not to read out loud,
how to fuck things up.
Uh,
how
to make your wife mad at you for three days in a row.
Sure.
I have that mastered.
What was you,
what was your masterclass?
Well,
I,
I did it because my friend Jay Roach who directed Austin Powers,
he directed my masterclass.
So it's basically several days of talking to Jay Roach who's asking me
questions.
There's no crowd or anything like that.
It's like a Ted talk or anything.
No,
it's just a name you just edited,
edited up and uh,
and I think it came out really well.
You know,
the thing you probably know because you've worked with a lot of people and staff
is so much of it is just inspiring people to work hard.
People are so damn lazy,
like people just don't put in the effort at all.
I told him,
I told someone that the other day,
I was like,
look,
you got to have a certain level of talent.
But what separates people is just like,
I mean the people who have like that work ethic and it's almost got to be like,
and people in this business,
I kind of workaholics.
Um,
and like I've learned that with F is for family.
Some of these people,
hey,
I want to go through it again.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I'm like,
these people are fucking insane.
Like they don't want to go home.
Um,
but the people that I saw like just really,
really,
really work.
I don't want to name any names because then if I don't name names,
people saying what he's saying,
I'm fucking lazy.
But I just,
I saw a lot of people that warrant the guy.
Yeah.
But work their way,
like into being the guy.
But like,
you know,
with you,
it's got to feel good when somebody comes to you and asked you to teach your
masterclass.
I mean you certainly have the body of work and all this stuff that you've done
it.
Cause I,
that's I think the last three times I've,
I've talked to you,
that is what I've asked you.
How do you and my delegation of that Shit,
cause I still want to be a comedian and still,
you know,
and the only way to go still be in good as you have to be out there doing it.
But if,
if,
how do I,
you know,
but I also love doing the show and then also got to be a dad.
Like how do,
how,
how the fuck do you balance all of it?
So some of that in,
in there.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I think that like a lot of it is a [inaudible] that you're just pushing,
pushing balls forward.
So you may be on the road doing standup and you have a great idea for a movie
and it's just making sure in some consistent way you're pushing it forward and
making progress.
Now you might finish it in three months,
you might finish it in three years,
but if you have four or five things going at the same time,
that's really what it is,
is,
you know,
I might get up in the morning and go from the moment I get up to lunch,
I'm going to work with Pete.
And in the afternoon you,
I'm doing a movie with p Davidson.
I'm going to rewrite p Davidson and then did you ever get burned out?
Do you get frustrated?
The Illusia Tempe seem like a chill guy.
Is this like a,
is this how you are or like you behind the scenes,
you one of those guys throw in laptops.
Like it doesn't work where I'm going to stay here all night where I only get
crazy on two issues.
What,
like two or three issues.
One is if the food orders wrong,
I just,
I,
I can't handle it.
Like if they don't bring the salsa with the Burrito,
like I,
I'm so reward myself with that.
That could go viral.
That could go bad.
You're,
you're,
uh,
you're flipping out.
That's okay.
That's,
that's,
that's understandable by,
by moments of shame or I go,
you really lost it are mainly around food.
But the areas where I get crazy one is I used to people who tell me I couldn't
have my casting and that would always drive me crazy if I said,
you know who the star of the show should be?
It should be Jason Segel and then Fox would go,
no,
that's where my head would explode.
And where would you explode on the phone to them?
In your car to your windshield?
Every,
every scenario.
I mean,
I,
I'd be,
I'd be screaming,
I'd be in tears.
I would be threatening.
I'd have agents calling and I never won.
As a result,
it took me years to realize,
oh,
all my emotional reactions have never won the fight.
And then when I stopped behaving that way,
I started winning more of those debates.
But I would get so upset because to me the worst thing in the world is if you
have an edited a movie and someone forces you to change it and you've ruined
your own movie to,
to something.
Does that happened?
Well,
it,
I,
that's the one area I just can't allow to happen.
Now.
I have had things changed in the past that I look back at more so,
you know,
a couple of decades ago where I did give in and neck,
even right now I thought about that movie and be like,
Oh,
why did we cut that scene?
They told us to cut that scene and there was a scene in way
you failed because you were young and just trying to get your foot in the door.
Every,
everybody always says that thing,
you know,
you just gotta let him get him,
get you the first time,
and then the next time you'll be able to write your own ticket.
Now do you,
do you subscribe to that?
Well,
I think it's true.
Only in the sense that you can't win.
You just don't have the power.
Right.
So we made this movie heavyweights and Paul Feig was in it and still are played
the bad guy who was a summer camp for fat kids.
Uh,
and it was a,
it was a Disney movie.
And then when we finished it and see real directed it and wrote it with me,
uh,
it was just a little darker than any Disney movie you've ever seen.
And it ended with,
uh,
with,
so it was funny.
It was funny and not in the way that a lot of those movies are still here at the
end of the movie.
He's lost his mind.
He's the owner of this fat camp and he's like this like demented Tony Robbins
guy and he's got a bow and Arrow and he's like threatening to kill all the
children.
Right.
And Disney said,
you know,
you really can't have him.
Lake point pointing bow and arrows from Jill at children are like three feet
away.
Right.
And so we had to re add it,
the sequence.
That's the kind of stuff.
I'll wake up at two in the morning and go,
why did we cut out the goddamn bow and Arrow sequence still eats at you?
And I might have five of those.
And so that's where I can
what point in your career where you're like,
all right,
Jed.
Screaming at people and flipping out during these moments isn't working.
Yeah.
Like how did you,
cause I am like,
my big Achilles heel is,
is uh,
it's not anybody,
it's funny.
It's not at work.
I don't flip out.
Yeah.
In comedy clubs,
I don't,
I've never flipped out at,
uh,
F as a family have raised.
My Voice of it is just cry.
Wait,
how do we talk about,
but I never like got to the point of light,
you know,
never had a big,
storm out fucking throwing shit.
Never had one of those.
But like,
it's more like at,
at,
at home.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
you know,
I just like flip out about just stupid shit.
Like I fucking suck at these iPhones and laptops I get,
so I'm so frustrated because I don't like them.
Technology doesn't fascinate me.
It's not something I'm interested in.
It's really,
it's ruined the world.
So,
and you know,
little ways it has it now,
the other ways it hasn't
medic medically is,
it's nice when your kids are older and they don't look up at you for hours.
You'll,
you'll go through in the way.
Yes.
I,
yeah,
that aspect of it.
But I definitely like,
uh,
like I just don't like how yesterday I knew how to use this device and then now
I don't know,
I have to go through this fucking bullshit.
It's just every time,
you know,
you move three feet ahead,
they knock you back with the new updated system and then you can't,
you can't opt out of not updating.
It cause you to be able to keep your phone for years and they're just like,
no,
we're going to fill up this fucking phone until you have to bring it in.
And then we're gonna take everything off it and sell it to some kid in the
Philippines and you just feel like you're just part of this thing.
And like that's the type of shit,
like I'm trying to,
uh,
you know,
and I'm failing miserably at it.
But explain the flip out.
Is that alone?
Like throwing it against the wall.
Are you yelling at another person?
Like what does it turn into?
I just literally like,
my wife will be just totally chilling,
watching TV and then out of nowhere I'll just be like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
You fucking piece of shit.
I flip out like that and like what?
I don't know,
cause I grew up with that.
I didn't understand what it was doing to her as far as just really just having
her be on edge and uh,
yeah.
So I mean,
how did she tell you not to do it?
What's her,
her approach to telling you to chill out?
Oh man,
she's just straightforward teeth.
Straight forward.
She said,
she said some shit,
I'm not going to,
you know,
this is too intimate detail,
but she said some shit to me like two days ago that I will never forget.
And I was like,
wow,
well good.
When you have,
you did,
it changes everything because you're,
she knows you're about to do it in front of a child that understands it.
So when they're little,
they're babies and you can go in the other room,
but at some point you just spend so much time with your kid that they will
absorb it and then you go to,
I like the way I move in the world cause I think my kid's going to copy it.
Yeah.
So fortunately I am really on my best behavior for the most part around my kid.
She seen me flip out a few times,
but I quickly tried to turn it in and do a joke.
But,
um,
it's something,
yeah,
I got to go to therapy dude.
Cause I,
I,
I don't wanna cause she's getting to the point now where she's repeating stuff
and I just don't,
I don't want to,
this is the deal.
She's not going to be like me.
I already know she's not going to be like me,
uh,
as far in a good way.
So I mean that's,
that's kind of what,
what does that say about me?
Like,
my job as a dad is to make my kid not like me.
Well,
the one thing,
half of me,
but I don't want you to be me at all.
I want you to be like your mom.
Well,
they don't really,
the damage of
us,
you know?
So that's something I've noticed is,
you know,
my kids are hilarious,
but they're neurotic kids too,
but they didn't go through some of the intense things and I went through that,
really built how my mind works.
But I'm sure they have their own,
their own menu.
No,
I bet there's a whole new level of shit with just like social media didn't
exist.
So like what I liked about my childhood was once school was over,
the ass kicking was over,
whatever thing,
humiliation.
I could go home.
It was fine.
It didn't continue.
The Mike Douglas show was on,
you'd watch it heal.
Yes.
There wasn't this think tank of kids trying to,
you know,
getting all online and pile on you and the shit that they deal with.
So,
and they know when they're being excluded.
So the biggest issue is because of Instagram,
you're aware of what you've been invited to.
So when people are hanging out you're like,
oh,
they didn't want me at this thing.
When I was a kid,
I was excluded by everybody.
I had one or two really good friends.
But basically if I thought about it,
if I think about it now,
I was excluded from every possible social thing that was happening at the club.
But I,
but I didn't know it.
You know,
I just would go home every day and just watching the Dinah shore show and be
fine and wait for my friends to get back from football.
But now the kids know like,
oh,
those three girls went to the mall.
Oh,
those two are hanging out at this concert.
And they feel bad.
No.
And then they take a picture,
which is not an accurate depiction of what that's like.
It's like,
it's like they're selling the movie of like their,
their,
their life or anything.
So that's the,
uh,
that's the thing I get nervous with.
And that's been,
you know,
a source of,
uh,
you know,
back and forth.
Me and my wife is like,
I don't like her watching TV and all of this shit and I don't like you're eating
junk food and uh,
you know,
and she has more of like,
like she wants a little bit TV.
She occasionally has Mcdonald's and it's like,
it's like,
all right,
but you know,
I mean,
this is the fights you have because yeah,
you,
when you're married,
you're instantly deciding how much do I care about each thing and what,
how far do I want to push my wife?
Like in knocked up one of the scenes that I like,
but it's a,
it's an intense scene is Leslie sitting there and she's looking at a website
that tells her where sexual predators live in the neighborhood.
And Paul comes in and he just keeps making jokes about it and she's really
freaked out.
Like,
do you know there's a guy like three,
three streets over and Paul keeps making jokes like,
well,
let's not go to his house on Halloween.
And then finally she's like,
that's what I would do.
And then she finally says like,
sometimes I just want to rip your fucking head off because you're so fucking
stupid.
And that really is what marriage is about.
Is there,
there are issues that you care about.
Like how much of Mcdonald's should the kitty?
Now when I was a kid,
I swear to God,
I had McDonald's.
I'm not kidding you six times a week.
And I loved it.
I ate it.
My mom had no issue taking me there every single time.
We used to go out as a family,
like it was fine dining.
He got there,
we had a big family.
So it was five cheeseburgers,
five small fries,
five chocolate shakes,
two big MACs,
two large fries to coax.
That was the order for a years.
And it was awesome every time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was an ice being jealous.
And when I got older,
because I kept getting a cheeseburger and I was big enough to get a quarter
pounder with cheese,
but I was afraid to ask as you get shit.
And I just,
we looking at theirs and they would only like halfway through it with that
little mouse trying to eat it.
And I have Woolston mind down.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I remember when I used to,
when I was really young and I lived on the north shore of Boston.
I remember there was a Mcdonald's and it was this train track that was right by,
and you would throw some of your French fries to the seagulls and you get to see
a train go by and you'd be sitting outside.
And it was like some of my fondest memories as a kid and um,
you know,
yeah,
there was no,
yeah.
You know,
they will roughly the same age.
So it was just all a,
you know,
peanut butter and fluff and all of these,
these,
um,
there's some of this out about it.
It,
when did you even realize Mcdonald's was bad and what,
like how old were you when you were like,
I guess I shouldn't eat them?
Well,
you knew fast food was bad,
but he didn't know to the point like,
I make Mcdonald's,
remember a few years ago they had a bolt in a bulletin board.
A billboard just came out and it's like now with a 100% beef,
which is obviously,
well what the fuck was it before the page?
Did you watch that movie founder with Michael Keaton?
Oh you gotta watch that Michael Keaton's amazing in that movie and it's such a,
it's such a well done a movie about like all of that type of stuff.
So,
um,
but then,
you know,
your wife says,
ah,
I want to give her the kid and some Mcdonald's and you're like,
they could let be awful.
Now I have the poisoned,
I have the reverse with my wife used to be poised.
I think now it's more like,
it's a little more healthy right now.
It might be just nothing this blank,
no positive anything.
But my,
my wife early in our relationship when I would get Mcdonald's would look at me
like,
what is wrong with you?
Are you an adult?
Like you eat this food?
She was so disgusted.
She shamed me to such an extent that I don't even sneak out and get it.
Like she,
she programmed me to be disgusted by the thing that made me so happy.
Yeah.
My thing was when I was going to be healthy,
I went to Wendy's cause Wendy's seemed like it was actually burger meat.
Yeah.
Probably wasn't either.
No,
it probably wasn't.
Well,
dude,
um,
I gotta tell you,
man,
it's such a thrill to have,
uh,
someone like you come on on the show and like,
and I really appreciate the advice both on this and an off that you've given me
as far as like,
how do you know,
you know,
keep it all kind of going without,
without screwing it up.
And now I'm definitely gonna check out that master class that you're in.
Everybody check out,
uh,
January 15th guy that the Grammercy.
Um,
I want you want to say hotel Gramercy theater.
I mean John Malaney,
uh,
Pete Holmes,
jet appetite for the Ronald McDonald House is going to be a go to [inaudible]
dot com slash tour once against season of crashing with the Great Pete Holmes.
Um,
January in January,
January.
Garry Shandling documentary is on Blu Ray and,
uh,
it's masterclass.com where you can,
just I guess,
imagine search Judd Apatow and Pete Holmes,
new special airs,
I think on the 15th,
which is,
he's got a great new stand up.
What's it called?
It's called a dirty,
clean,
dirty,
and where it,
where can they see that?
That'll be on HBO on Hbo.
I love it.
I want this.
Why?
Why wouldn't it be nice to go?
He said,
busy with them.
All right,
Jeff,
thank you so much for coming in and everybody thank you for listening.
And a checkout.
Judd Apatow,
January 15th,
Gramercy theater.
All right buddy.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Bye.